Peter talked about getting involved with
this and and meeting the director Bob
Clark I'd been acting since
two-and-a-half and you get all these
auditions that they consolidate sort of
in two days and I remember reading for
this thing and it was called a Christmas
story and I gave it my best and I heard
nothing
for probably about two and a half months
and then I got a call to go up to Canada
and do a screen test where they take a
bunch of kids at that time they were
doing this where they sort of mix and
match and they do chemistry reads were
they and they kind of have you learn
every other role and each other person
learns them and they start to whittle it
down and they were sort of whittling
down the room and if you're asked to
leave they we say oh no it's fine but
you know it's a bad sign I was kept
making the grade and I was down to the
end and Bob said I'd like you to play
the part later found out I was the first
person he ever saw for the role and he
said oh I like the kid but obviously I'm
not gonna hire the first person I see so
he sort of went on this whole search and
it came back around and then I just yeah
which was a great experience for me I
got to I think it was Cleveland where we
were shooting first or Canada and Bob
said oh I just finished the movie I last
shot you want to come see it and was
Porky's - my mom had some reservations
about what she got me into on this one
but we kind of forged the head into the
winner in Cleveland working outside in
pajamas and sort of all the other things
and I've the last thing that I remember
was that I think the downtown had either
you had got them to do whether they had
a lot of the Christmas decorations sort
of still up so as a kid it felt a lot
like Christmas was continuing so there
was something very magical and fun about
that the great thing about Bob and I did
as you know Porky's went into we did
Christmas story and then I did another
picture with Bob later on some years
later for a designer Bob let you do the
movie let you deliver the movie so you
know you came to him with your drawings
you know and your concepts and
ever and you know like III don't
remember having anything with Bob that
it was like no I don't think so you know
like he he you couldn't miss it was
always there in the paper you know so it
just jumped out at you and particularly
with Christmas story I don't know
anybody who has a child did not grow up
wanting that really special special gift
and you waited till the 99th hour and
you just don't think you're gonna get it
and it's just just getting really bad
and and then you know it's right at the
end and it's like well this is it and
there it is and it's like wow and that's
the magic of the movie I think you know